no please tell me you don't know the
story about me sitting next to the older
gentleman who was he had a tight
moustache he was looking down on me he
had been in the military a long time
button-down gentleman and like you said
said III I said well if you're in LA you
know if you ever want to know places to
eat let me know and you know give you my
number he goes alright I'll give you my
number but if I make a friend it's a
friend for life
I'm just warning sir general X any okay
well there it is then no I I'll do you
one better I think I told you this they
haven't told the audience this I'm at
the economy store this guy I'm gonna
group with a group of friends link tell
this guy wants to talk to me
grown man all of me 46:40 junk trios bro
was last time he threw the football
around IO excuse me as I yeah what's
this thing if you were ballin all right
but I don't know man use what are you
doing Saturday I went uh probably with
my family is let's go to the park let's
play catch throw the wrong road man
let's throw the wrong man was some
pattern let's just let's just play cat
let's do the rock around it well well no
no and I thought he's joking around 30
is [ __ ] you have to turn up like
captured other immense you I'm a bit
want by cat I could not stop laughing I
think you don't know cursor leo and he
was in tears laughing I went bro that
guy just asked me to play catch in
pflueger's why I went dead serious he
just had so I want to go the park on
Saturday play camp probably thought you
wanted to work off some cobwebs you know
like get back to the old glory days but
that's what the best is out of Noah dude
well this time threw the rock around uh
I could not tell you let's play catch
let's play some catch we're doing
Saturday not playing catch with the show
is Saturday I'll Drive up you know what
you do is alternate frisbee and then go
[ __ ] each other that's a good that's a
terrible idea
let's play seven let's play some frisbee
golf you know we should do we should
play freeze tag and slit our wrists
how's that say what though I went I
drove a long way yesterday with my kids
long way out in Thousand Oaks to dojo
boom where it's basically Ninja Warrior
for is it all trampolines though is it
trampolines slack lines I mean all kinds
of [ __ ] roll up that spring on the
ground soft so when they fall paradise
it was a bigger kids played forever yeah
they paid they played I was like we'll
go to four they're not gonna last till
for the quit at three now were they were
like let's keep going Tony Jefferies had
a bouncy castle at his little girls he
has three girls his little girls like
birthday party rocks and run first you
don't have your kids birthday party at
your gym anyways cheetah hashtag cheap
but he has tech saving money but he had
a bouncy castle and I've never seen my
son in one and he was a little reserved
at first that he got in there oh I don't
know he's in there for two and a half
hours okay I'm talking like he just ran
two goddamn Boston Marathon yes dripping
sweat yep love it they will not stop and
the pools the same way pools a great
babysitter because it also kills more
kids than anything else in America but
yeah I hear goddamn right it does as
William crack because you know why you
drown so silently so quickly it's a
[ __ ] disaster
Jesus bro yeah dude last night was fun
if I'm at the store I feel like you and
I haven't been in a while together I
know you've been on the road you shut
your specials - and then you we've just
been missing each other I've been busy
been busy and fine tonight we're last
night we're both its economy store Emma
with Bert Kreischer has a special coming
out next week yes he doesn't Chrysler
special on Netflix it's drop and he's
when the funniest man in the world but
hilber was the old Bert popped in yeah
dude no into a new [ __ ] new material new
bill burr front for me if you know
everyone has a cup of tea yeah you can't
rank it but I think he's he's the best
comic in the world I think he's numero
uno that's very first debate broken hair
here any given night you're there but
they to me
night after night numero uno yeah I
would agree Bill burr to me makes me
laugh so [ __ ] hard he's so original
he's change everything he doesn't makes
me laugh yeah you're not you're not
silly like us nah like we were talking
on the back you know I was like oh yes
feels basically angry yeah you know
Bills Bills always it's funny cuz I go
coming back on the pocket I thought you
guys were one and done like Marin I
don't know squeezes yeah you got
everything
I don't know that [ __ ] I don't know he's
a monster man yeah yeah he does he does
just stand up and you know says funny
said I said you know I gotta write a new
[ __ ] now and he's kind of in the same
position Rogen's in the same position
we're trying to come up with like a
whole new hour and and bill said just do
something you're not good at just go try
some [ __ ] you'll find it funny stuff
just what I find different with Bill
Rosen saying where do I find different
with Bill burr is he he's not scared
like he takes command of the audience so
he comes out there and they're a little
tightness what the [ __ ] wrong with you
guys what are you tired yeah the [ __ ]
you want to be doing a joke can we get
the [ __ ] off what's wrong with you yeah
and he's a new thing here you wanna hear
or not something that's gay yeah well
[ __ ] man here it is and then just like
you can tell like there's no did you
ever see the video of him and fulfilled
we don't before that's what made him
famous play that play that Jim famous we
do we play they were booing everybody
off the stage okay was the Opie and
Anthony show I think opening up things
they really booing everybody on stage
how long does this this was exactly six
years ago now way longer than these ten
years ago at least note six been posted
the video switcher but it's 10 years old
easy
[Applause]
now he's telling the Philadelphia he's
telling all of that what they can do
this the best footage to the ideas 11
minutes fact he goes he basically
they're being literally
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
grab you by the [ __ ] hair but you
don't have it
I really hope you run into all those
black people that you love so much
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
if you take some balls to do this man
ten minutes five minutes left I'm doing
all fifteen minutes ten minutes left do
it off [ __ ] job guys hi IRA my shirt for
this [ __ ]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Applause]
and they love it Ian stop it Jim Jesus
rush payday he got so angry immigrants
never did it because they were all out
there to do stand-up and before him oh
so many comics we were just kidding it
says Bill burr Philly rant what actually
has so what happened was like on that
yeah so what I was before it was like a
it was like a it was a bunch of guys
that opened Opie and Anthony we're gonna
come out so like the Eagles are playing
the Cowboys or something yeah and we're
like this is a [ __ ] comedy show they
haven't like a preseason game here next
like what's going on so we got in there
and yadda yadda yadda it's still broad
daylight because it's summer it's
outside and the place holds ten thousand
people and maybe like I don't know
thirty five forty percent are in there
maybe twenty percent are sitting it down
the rest are walking around you trying
to find their seat and Vause goes out
and responds the first act who I'm not
gonna name his name cuz he got booted he
went out there he was from Philly had
all his family there and all that type
of stuff and it's not da my rare if
everybody keeps guessing that one it was
broad daylight he goes out there and
just does his act and within I don't
know how many minutes he starts getting
booed and dude everybody backstage is
just going like Oh God in their own way
going yeah it's gonna be one of these
right and I'm looking at the list how
far down the list am i this is how it's
starting so he goes out there and like
by the end of his act it was this core
group of people that started booing him
and then it got a little bit bigger so
there was probably like maybe a thousand
people just chanting [ __ ] it Darren
that had to give birth I'm like as
they're chanting [ __ ] II just goes
thanks a lot you guys been great good an
absolutely stunned look on his face and
I went up to him to try to console him
and I was kind of doing that do dude
while kind of laughing because he had
this stun like what the [ __ ] was that
so then Voss goes out
vos goes out and he starts doing time
and you gotta understand boss is doing
with time in front of a crowd that's
sort of going I don't know why we
started maybe it was one of those things
you had to be out of the venue by a
certain amount of time as people were
getting [ __ ] up and they were still
throwing footballs around and we're
walking into the stadium and Vaz starts
trying to do his [ __ ] which was
impossible doing it was like this bright
Sun it was pretty long Justin long so
they is it turn it on him and 11 minutes
he's going tough you know watch your
mouth or I'll bring so-and-so back and
he any [ __ ] on the first guy and to me
he just turned the keys over to the
crowd where they do the Caesar thumbs-up
thumbs-down oh boy it's just which is
the [ __ ] right it's like sand the vibe
I don't like right up yeah dude the
alive but the line-up was insane like
every comic Tracy Morgan Patrice O'Neal
Saget Robert Kelley Don Meyer era myself
Opie and Anthony and Jim Norton closing
yeah amazing I mean yeah I don't know
like what's his I knew something was
[ __ ] up when Tracy Morgan went out and
he was supposed to do 15 to 20 and he
pulled up at about 7 minutes 50 seconds
in the middle of a book just stopped and
went thank you good night god bless I
just put the thing down and you know
that deal dude you do those uptown rooms
they boo in those and you go into the
black rooms enough you can feel a boo
coming yeah and he was just looking
around he saw the he's although oh the
ocean go out anyways oh there's a
tsunami coming [ __ ] it [ __ ] do to the
night
ut look these this bunch of crazy drunk
white people they not gonna remember if
I did seven minutes or 17 he's right god
bless I'm out put down the mic and
[ __ ] walked off to live but back
didn't stop this was so long ago you
didn't have cameras on your phones no
it's all I know so that was done Rana
some somebody took that video with a
video camera so that's a while yeah it
was a long time ago man I remember when
Eddie IFFT wasn't want to show that to
me and it was like forever ago but it
was like a talk I'm sure of the yeah
because bill was Noah's a very small
comic back then he was you know he was
doing the road the circuit had been for
20 years you know this this bill success
has been fairly recent
but they were also dealing with a dude
who had been doing stand-up you know the
pros every [ __ ] weekend for 20 years
and he was like really alright
that's hilarious he went at him and
that's what they and then but the
problem was after after that this is do
get out yeah bill would get out there
twelve years ago bill would get out
there and do [ __ ] and they'd be like
they'd boo him so they could so he did
yeah
that's freaking hilarious yeah well we
got in that rant but either way is great
seeing him last night that was one of
the first actually times that I camera
where the Internet
boosted somebody that was like that one
of the first times it's something went
viral I remember you know everybody was
sharing that in the comedy world and
everyone else I met the first person I
know that went super virus Kimbo Slice
everyone in my neighborhood was like
dude have seen that black guy and
Miami's [ __ ] fighting Jews for money
yeah they turned like oh [ __ ] he looks
scared
yeah like holy [ __ ] then you watch those
they're so fun to watch even today they
are the [ __ ] you know I you know who
else who used to fight in that league or
and with that a night with bad goats was
um 170 pounder now in the USC the [ __ ]
is his name okay Oh Jorge Muslim yeah
yeah yeah oh yeah yeah he's a young kid
there's videos of him yeah but nothing
like Kim Bum akimbo [ __ ] was just
legendary man yeah we fought that cop me
put my submission everyone like freaked
the [ __ ] out like what are you doing
when the cop did yeah I remember that
cop was a giant guy it was so cool man
[ __ ] he's like the first like phenom he
played high level football right just
high school oh we didn't play in Miami
though oh okay no the straws are so
great though those street fights the
arguments a he's the reason why MMA so
mainstream cuz here's the first like
superstar you know like legit I mean as
far as like kids go Chuck Liddell was
big in like the underground scene and
then got big people were talking voice
was big but he wasn't never like this
crossover super spy weird Kimbo Slice
you weren't even an MMA fan you know but
you know who Kimbo Slice was yeah and
then when he signed with Scott Coker and
lead X E
you're like holy [ __ ] mm-hm it was so
cool man those were the days there's
there's her husband all right there so
old-school man out yeah already so final
due to a lot bigger than Terry he's
young yeah fighter man goddamn akimbo is
a big deal man yeah you had good things
to say about him
loved them yeah did you notice my well
there are the shoelace you upset they do
there are the shoes they're my brother
scrooge mcduck with Richie Richie
yes yes they were made for you they were
made just as wisely custom yes I
understand we have some custom ones what
we put on yours mine ah too old for
these what if we just put like red dots
on those so I like match entire buy so
it looks like you're wearing a onesie
psoriasis shoes like a 1 1 z butt naked
good can they have toes so the volume on
yeah that's a good idea yeah or or
they're just or it just says your tools
or a zzzzz zzzz what we could do they
can customize anything dude
yeah now are those very comfortable very
comfortable yeah what is it about the
easiest just that they're easy huh mmm
yeah they're making more and more
available though yes are you having
social media girl Kat has easy Zahn look
at those those are dull see that yes
okay better more on stage yesterday I
was watching you at the comic store and
there were 20 ladies that seemed to have
a thing for you because you were talking
about how you're addressed and they were
like clapping and they liked it they
liked the fashion thought you were hot
they were whispering were they older
yes very young oh yeah they're kind of
like wispy with when girls like see see
guys I don't know guys are kind of quiet
about it guys will just be like you know
just look with the girl girls get
detailed the girls will start whispering
I don't know what they're talking about
but they're they're like they'll start
kind of like the look and then they'll
start conversing
it becomes this energy if they're all
like they don't want confirmation like
are you you know yeah they're all a
titter over its got like if I'm with my
boys you know cars like damn you see
that purple
GTS yeah like can you see this then we
all start talking about it Mike I want
to I want make sure everyone
knows that the dope guard going by yeah
well my wife was uh you with all her
friends for this charity I had chris
d'elia get up and it was when he used to
do the drunk girl I love that it goes
back in time they were laughing the
girls were laughing my wife and her
friends were laughing so hard at that
drunk girl think they were laughing so
hard they were crying and then they were
all of them married and then they all
said in his head it started becoming
baby bird there was a yeah there was
this buzz a gift that I was watching
that's were at each other and talk and I
was like yeah you and I said heads
Turkey she goes she goes did what they
were all they thought he was cute and
they were they thought it was hot no one
suck his dick I think what they say as
they go something like I like his pants
and what's his hair no hair wouldn't
work on most people but it doesn't you
know then there's always the one [ __ ]
in the group like so in psycho I like
his shoes I like his necklace and then
you hear whatever that the girl from
second the city what was the main so
right what's the main told the [ __ ]
Samantha there's always a Samantha new
group yeah and then I like your shoes I
kiss teeth I wanna suck his dick like
god I don't think so I was like oh I
would love no starts going around and
that's like they're one up and each no
that's not you know Chris is on all
fours skin is sucked
yeah the rusty trombone I've seen the
Hat there's some metal saying I work on
TV I don't know about in real life very
sexy woman very you know her Jessica
Parker hate each other um I didn't see
that I'm not saying now they've been
talking mad [ __ ] they've been talking
about [ __ ] to each other oh really
yeah I would imagine Kim Cattrall
started that I don't know that's the
rumor Sarah Jessica Parker's very demure
about things that's the room how about I
did kill Tony on Monday hilarious show
but there was a transgender person got
up how do I thought of you because you
know it was a female that went that
that's trying to be a male okay you know
and has hormones and did steroids and
was in bodybuilding and Tony said it
perfect cuz someone goes are you into
this antonio's Oh
yeah yeah yeah I love I love a lot of
girls with circular faces and then men's
bodies cuz her fate like she she's I
freeze she had like a yeah Ted Bundy was
a girl she was a guy becoming a girl no
got a girl becoming a guy yes and like
it was hard to tell because you can open
mic right so kill Tony people come up
draw name in a hat they called her if
your name was Tonya and she gets up and
then you know she goes III you guys are
all looking here I don't know what
bathroom I should go in ether you know
it's the way she opens I know you guys
are looking at me I don't know what
bathroom to go in either she was like a
fanny pack and even I was like is it a
dude like you looks more like a dude but
there's a little bit of feminine energy
and then you go oh there it is yeah
that's right there Wow tough so then I'm
not too bad-looking that bounce see that
as a serial killer face oh you mean kind
of just white guy glasses the hair yeah
nondescript whoa
is there check this out so closet for a
second chin he goes but she has a good
posture and assets yeah I knew I thought
of you I thought probably would be into
this yeah not in a weird way I thought
Bryan would love to suck your dick so
anyway so I was saying though I would
love not your Trumbo no so no I was
thinking of you at that exact moment or
to God but but no let's Oprah Tony goes
how do you make money and she and he
goes I hopefully she went she wants to
be called a he I don't know the pronouns
right now so I he goes oh from my webcam
Terri's what kind of stuff to you in
your webcam shows how much he goes can
you do it here just she was done with
her stand-up he was done with his stamp
so I apologize I don't know what to say
so um she goes sure well how much can I
do and he goes what's on [ __ ] you know
people are eating for God's sakes you
don't need to get your [ __ ] out so
she she took off its his clothes yeah
and then started flexing cuz used to be
in body build a lot of steroids oh oh
really
as a gal yes good body right there I see
I thought of you bro
cuz right she did have an ass on him and
you can see me checking that ass out I
see a woman there okay I think I think
she judged he or she was just
controlling whatever and she wants to be
yeah she was cool you know there was a
transgender in the front row
thing that kept staring each other but
look out I cannot stop laughing I was
sober by the way but had an ass on him
yeah there was a transgender front who
looked like a straight dimepiece and
they were like flirting with each other
did you see the transgender that that's
who's a famous porn somebody the blonde
at the Comedy Store with giant tits and
was just wearing a shirt last night
straps over the nipple last night
this was no is the last time I was there
actually I don't think so yeah this one
I saw just Tony goes aren't you
transgender and he goes now did you did
you used to have a dick she's like yes
and I was like damn that used to be a
dude Wow bro
you give me one tequila shot yeah trick
me well you know something from Vermont
has now nominated a transgender woman
hmm
as governor oh that's a cool nominated
that's cool yeah so no that's not her
that's have it somewhere but yeah the
the that kill Tony is a fun [ __ ] show
man
it's so fun some people get up there you
know they do one minute of stand-up some
people go up they do great then some go
up man just you can tell they've never
done stand-up before yeah what they
thought was funny in their bedroom when
he do it on my yeah it's kind of fun to
see though yeah well you know that's
like anything else you think you're a
tough guy step in the ring see what
happens was he getting punched back just
you know fun to see and then the best
part is Jeremiah you know every night
the band has a theme and their theme was
Red Hot Chili Peppers so he came out and
just like a thong you know and was
singing like him and he was on fire
couldn't make anyone laugh and then they
go away it's almost the end of the show
him and the drummer go away and I'm like
I think him where the [ __ ] to Jamaica so
we're talking people with ever young
people and then Jeremiah and his boy
jump out from the curtains and you know
the famous Red Hot Chili Peppers on
their butt naked
yeah he's butt-naked has a socket on his
[ __ ] and he's a huge 70s porno bush they
didn't shave a little trim jumped out
and he jumped out with aa and the crowd
goes and I go damn dawg and he was like
you can tell he thought he was like yeah
no but he was and they sits down and can
tell you it like we're just roast
on his bush for like I don't know 10
minutes yeah and then it gets quite he
goes I thought this was no dear friend I
thought I just get a better response I'm
gonna go change any left as well he
should it was hilarious though like yeah
no no energy okay see you later and now
been funny if we went oh alright these
work did one turn back around on don't
be sat there with a sock on his dick
well things will do it was hilarious for
for the giggle it was hilarious also
also trim your but don't get crazy with
your Bush I miss his wife was there last
night culture I want to say do you got
it have to do something your man's Bush
like yeah um to trim that [ __ ] down I'm
talking full-blown crazy like a like a
wild the guy who painted on TV like that
keep warm in the wind yes yeah it was
you don't need pants
but dude how does how's your wife not
say some acting class would always have
a guy who would be naked in the scene it
was always a love scene there was a
hairdresser and he he would he would act
you know he was he was really into heavy
scenes and yeah he's one of those guys I
was like it's never gonna happen for you
just didn't have it you just one of
those guys with like run a pattern oh
you can't run run so that's probably the
same guy think he just got an ego
because I said it he everything he did
when he acted was incredibly profound
over ever deep yeah and he held it and
he and there you go yeah well good and
then he would cry like this uh-huh it
was it was it was terrible but fun to
what I like whoa - watch me - I love
terrible wife the best the best he would
like he would do these weird martial art
moves and one day he took his clothes
off and walked across the stage and he
had an innie he he was a muscular guy
who did a lot of bench a lot of bench
and like dry cept and that's the yeah
and but peacock a true peacock spent a
lot of money on his hair products and
obviously face moisturizer and fans
himself a ladies man had a convertible
one of those cars and you know macho
this guy sounds pretty I had a
yeah and had a had it was just a bush it
was a he was a giant of Harry Potter oh
god oh god it was it I think that sherry
seventies vagina that I was like would
you don't worry your day when you were
just can't walk across they can do that
you look bigger if you shave it well
also even if it's small we shave it so
it's better presentable yeah but it this
was presentations also to a point where
I was like you should never take your
clothes off it's almost like he
blow-dried his pubes and like effort
like picked it and also his dick was a
little is a thing yeah it was like half
a dumb it was the first knuckle of a
thought I that's a favor and that's fine
but you don't want to go showing that
off will you shave the [ __ ] tree man
yeah and also we're gonna talk about
through the whole scene is your tiny
notes all anyone can focus yeah that's
it bro sure my way dude
great great approach like the effort but
with that Bush it's all we can focus on
should we thought this bro can't have
the 70s Bush acting schools have some
weird [ __ ] to go on one guy think
everyone like you're all those like
groups there's always like the weird odd
ball right specially and acting yeah
yeah cuz how many people come out here
and go I won't be in movies okay yeah
are you in acting class no I will that's
probably the first step I'd say probably
go to that and see if you even like it
then we get the acting class do you got
to pay to be there cuz it's the way it
works you know just same as college you
gotta pay for the classes and there's no
one there really unless you're at
Brian's level to say you there's certain
levels right there's the introduction
then there's advance like Brian's level
where you've been there for a while your
honor you're working a lot you show you
with the lead of the lead if not anyone
can just get in those classes but they
have the general classes as a general if
you go in it looks like an AAA meeting
that's weird you walk in and you're like
you better this class if that's exactly
in those classes and I went and I'm
gonna do everyone a favor in here no no
no no no no no maybe no no no maybe I
don't even see ya that's right just the
vibe sometimes though somebody makes it
through and you would never think in a
million years yes something oh yeah
there's just some people have it and
they just would they have a certain
angle but you and they work their ass
off if you saw Michael Pena I used to be
an acting class of Michael
Michel painting was always really good
but Michael Pena if you saw him in an
acting class sitting there that guy
really yeah but here's the thing they'll
be he's good at that that that in that
Lane yeah like he can be funny here be
real serious music like if you've seen
and also he's ethnic Latino so in that
Lane he's [ __ ] yeah really I think
it's only there's a lane for every yes
yes he's awesome he said he's a great
guy stand it was like really a gardener
Mexican guy really generation
mexican-american so much so he selearis
on chips he's a hilarious undeserving
report but and then he's also he but
when he's a bunch of funny movies but
then he's also super serious yes
in the end of watch yes but when you see
him in an acting class and he's just
sitting there you're not gonna go
definitely a bad guy
no just something about him did that you
believe there's some he had just an
intelligence to him
certain people are like that men Jayma
Mays Jayma Mays bring up Jim amazed at
JMA and I like that movie chips she was
an intern when I was doing a play when I
was 33 or something a long time dude how
about uh
and if JAMA never stopped working J Matt
Damon never stop working she's really
become a beautiful woman but when she
was 19 she was just dude how about how
about Dax Shepard who started his start
was on Punk'd yeah he was the guy who
did all the punks rash and Kuchar and
then [ __ ] blew up blew the [ __ ] up
mm-hmm I love those stories man oh yeah
intangible but they're not see read
stories like I'm sorry interrupt to be
the stories like Matthew McConaughey you
know you got discovered no oh he was
just at a bar super late night 2:00 in
the morning hanging out when he was in I
think was in Texas or maybe it's here in
Hollywood just moved here
no no acting no acting background
nothing when guy goes on I'm cast a
movie you you look like the guy was
thinking if you ever tried acting us
know he's you should do it well that was
that fast hire days what is it confuses
xeric never done it ever in his life he
has its first role now I understand that
story and I hear that storm don't
believe it I hear that story you don't
like that story I like it you know
Matthew McConaughey's teaches act and he
usually Texas sure do and tells the
students this sure does
and I again I like that story and he was
a young guy now here's the thing that we
all need to know as well is that that's
half true
you don't believe it well no it's it's
half true and you don't go to like
Juilliard or you don't he doesn't come
from up forward sorry no but Matt
McConaughey was also in LA to be an
actor and that I don't know if he got up
in LA though that's why I think it was
in Texas it might have been when they
were casting for the movie in Texas
you see they love casting and in the
stories he's at a bar story and I like
him but I like the story but you would
not like this right now I wasn't there
but I'm here to tell you that it's a
hundred percent false there are people I
suppose that get discovered but not true
it's directors that say some girl they
want to bang hey you should come
audition for my movie if Matthew
McConaughey was hanging out there with
his shirt off and who directed dazing
from use its I know I've done I don't
Richard this is van right he's a great
guy
he's a great guy there you go Daisy but
there it is Dazed and Confused audition
anyway so what I'm saying is that he was
still I believe Matthew McConaughey was
still there to be an actor Matthew
McConaughey had said his intention on
being an actor and that faithfully line
does not what got him to be an actress
line do you want to be an oh I'm sure
and he he had thought about it a lot
I'm sure he's young yeah but he was
Matthew McConaughey was a goal-oriented
guy he's a beast
he's a goal-oriented no he teaches
classes for free yeah to students for
free and usually I would say that I love
that stuff the opening acting class bro
maybe I will um you could do it for sure
yeah I could boys I've been offered by
your good teachers Playhouse yes I think
I'd be very good I understand acting so
I think I've gotta help people could be
cool but um you know I'm busy
you don't care I'm busy don't get done
on time maybe eventually we're not super
old
yeah when I'm older were a tweed jacket
come in glasses yeah pipe yeah
and then the kids look at you like
you're God this is really why a lot of
acting teachers really yeah I find a lot
like you should bum me out number one
you're when you're famous like it's like
the old it's like the old let's like the
old football coach bums me out the guy
who should have made it yeah then drops
all those stories on the all-time like
well god damn bro man I've heard from a
lot of you like Matthew McConaughey's a
great guy 30 [ __ ] guy I'm sure he
does that's aggressive but I'm sure he
does [ __ ] as well crazy all right
but I heard he's in shape and [ __ ]
lays down that Texas long one I'm sure
he does but um he like James Franco they
teach Franco class also yes box and now
he caught a case and it [ __ ] up his
movie yeah yeah you know what was his
movie though the worst movie it's got
you know disaster the disaster ours
which I loved
athos brilliant yeah she won a Golden
Globe for it he did because he didn't
win an Oscar he didn't win an Oscar he
didn't even nominate him because of that
[ __ ] because he had an acting class
where they were audition strippers and
he asked the strippers to take out their
tits then went what yeah yes yes how
dare you there was that one girl I guess
that dated him and she said that he kind
of pushed her head down and she didn't
want to and she's like no they did
anyway it was very shoddy and then she
continued to [ __ ] him afterwards and
they were girlfriend/boyfriend and what
the interviewer said [ __ ] you feels
like a skirt complicates your story she
goes well of course it does and it's
like well okay
cool it you know what's fun hold that
until his movie get wins a Golden Globe
and then go on the Oscars release it
then yeah you have no hidden agenda it
was a little it was a little [ __ ] up
is that
what an Oscar I thought it was terrible
that's what everyone wants that's his
[ __ ] way even said that's like [ __ ]
athlete right before a game seven to
five hold on hold on Brooklyn he did
steroids yeah [ __ ] [ __ ] you can't wait
to have two I win right and both of them
even said he's not Harvey Weinstein he's
not a bad guy but everyone got loved in
this yeah so he got [ __ ] benefit and
the end of the story
based on those two accusation fanfare to
cut him out of the picture on their
cover with no trial nothing they just
cut him out everyone's off that here
that's how that's how that's how it up
is that that's the environment Atticus
is entire life you know you won't give
that back you say she needs that
Julliard his last senior project you
have to shoot a documentary and he
approached Lorne Michaels that center
that live and what Helen do a
documentary and basically for a year he
followed center net live around although
their craziness the methods how they get
things done he followed that and that
was his documentary and that's how he
got really but after that you're like
holy [ __ ] yeah but that's that's just as
long as we don't ever say that you're
you're innocent until proven guilty in
this environment you're guilty by
accusation let's not lie about it let's
not pretend otherwise and so you don't
believe in you don't believe in habeas
corpus you don't believe in instant
guilty solely by Twitter yeah you
believe in just remember that you're
next in those situations you're next and
that's a terrible by the way I was gonna
say about teaching the acting class when
you're Matthew McConaughey James Franco
there's a lot of reward to teaching an
acting class for free it you're a star
you come in it's it's very easy it's a
lot of fun and you're you're a god
you're a god
did you know Jeff Goldblum same thing
you're a god when you walk in there and
there are nothing but gorgeous yes they
deserve deserve that they've worked very
hard to get there they're all wise like
you think in a super fight with Brock
Lesnar you've earned it yeah and they're
all watching you and you've earned it
now they're gonna gift them with their
talents Bryan that's what what they're
gonna have my talents I mean they're
gonna help you relax in the audition
studio famous actor I'm not gonna say
his name but my friend took a class of
ham Bruce Willis England no he's a
famous mr. J [ __ ] no but but a real
distinguished no DiCaprio in fact he's
he's older now so you may you would know
you know you know know and he she came
up to after and said I just want to tell
you I'm just such a huge fan and I want
to know if you had any advice and he
said well you just want to make sure you
would lack
shoulders him very tense he began to
massage it's a salt bridge yes here
massage her she was like not today all
right this guy's trying to [ __ ] me
well I should know better see ya later
you know sorry
you can't have that be she did back how
about yesterday on my way the commie
story you know when I haven't talked to
my dad in a while I forget how [ __ ]
smart my pops is he's a she's a very he
reads every bug
so I told me he'd I was in Dallas I mean
Jay were out there JFK I find it super
interesting my dad goes oh yeah I like
JFK I didn't know my dad [ __ ] had his
black belt and the Kennedys and was and
I was like this concise going through
conspiracy theories and he listens to
him he didn't interrupt me okay yeah
that's cool oh you think that yeah
that's cool Oh have you read have you
read this book I know I haven't I would
pick up that book now here's the problem
with your conspiracy and when I love him
for an hour Jeff came from the start is
childhood his father to his brother to
his other brother and then went Lana all
the way up to this I was like I knew I
knew all the details all dude he
explained the Jack Ruby everything I was
like God how do you know all this data's
you remember he was I watched all that
on TV yeah so then we knew that stuff
now I got older I was intrigued by it so
I read all the ways neighbor book use
name book rights and which one you're
reading right now and well I'm looking
these guys read that here's the problem
with that I'm like holy [ __ ] yeah I went
damn you know a shitload about JFK he
was most presence I do
it was so cool man yeah that's pretty
Dead Sea that's when you realize oh he's
an OG no I know I got to give him some
respect here no cuz cuz he was like
here's the thing I went like this here's
the thing go dad when they say it was a
simple shooter and I was like going
through it and I just I knew so much I'm
go mmhmm yeah that's interesting and you
know and governor what's the wrestler
that and then Jesse Ventura's I'm sorry
what was the name way Jesse I'm curious
mm-hmm and I just uh mmm-hmm I was like
oh I chair in comments I just quoted
Jesse pitcher to my father
yeah who's doing a smarter than
who's way smarter than me well you know
it's funny about all that is that um
what when I did the same that went
through the same thing with my father
when JFK came out I started reading all
the books and I was like definitely a
rifle team definitely conspiracy now my
father JFK was his hero yeah and and he
was also he was alive when it happened
he was 22 or something it was
devastating for him
davin there was 10 so he he read the
Warren Commission he read at all and as
always he's a historian basically so
he's always read everything from there
and did the same thing to me he just
shot holes and I liked it the thing is I
like it too but I love conspiracies huh
that's what people don't realize when I
go after Eddie and these guys
I love conspiracies they're so fun to
believe in and there are some conspiracy
especially this JFK yeah but and I still
believe with the JFK this I still
believe is more than any more - I agree
I don't know my dad made say because
there's more to it than were saying yeah
some of this stuff what else was
surprising I went we don't know I also
told my dad went god it's such a bummer
JFK was such a good guy whoa whoa would
you say he was like your gigas no it was
it no it was what book are you reading
yeah he was that thing with JFK he was
not a good guy he was it his did you
know he's a drug addict I'm like one he
was yeah he had a back we broke his back
in World War two on the ship and then he
was taking painkillers non [ __ ] stop
his name came addicted to him did you
see his do you see the medical when they
got into his medical archives did you
see the UH the amount of Medicine get a
carry he liked the [ __ ] he had like the
fuzz uh there's a recurrent him on the
show the gentlemen we've been talking
about today [ __ ] [ __ ] includes bill burr
his wife yes yes but but yes I saw the
list of drugs he would take on a daily
basis crazy we had a broken back [ __ ]
for his hardship for his digestion [ __ ]
for everything a lot of drugs he'd have
these parties constitute on his wife if
you watch the Jackie thing like his wife
was you know yeah she was like yeah yeah
not the best father yeah yeah tough man
quarter and I'll tell you what doesn't
float my seven to eight injections of
propane and it's back in the same
sitting I'll tell you what doesn't float
with my papi either I went yeah he's a
guy's guy though you know dad that's why
you're liking this you think that's a
guy's guy he's you think that's a guy's
guy
when I met like his style and then you
know like yeah he had a family but then
you know he's doing he was hold on and
then just [ __ ] an old-school morality
to my father same white dude that does
not play no and then my dad goes you got
a real Indian she also broke it down to
me which I thought was cool easy.you I
realized I grew up this you know in the
60s we were all scared for nuclear
warfare from Russia he goes so there was
a and he was it's also kind of happening
now same thing he was building bunkers
yeah
he and he you know my grandpa's in World
War two nut shot with machine gun and
all this crazy stories all this on my
whole family's from military almost
everyone my family's military and uncles
aunts grandma grandpa both sides
everyone to the military right and so
they're pretty [ __ ] hard on my dad
goes you know back back then the 6-2 we
were everyone was terrified goes so in
school we'd have drills if there's
nuclear bomb we'd get on their desk put
[ __ ] books on our head and I'm like
well that's gonna help you definitely I
can help and so then he talked to uh
because all his friends were doing it
all his friends parents were billing
these bunkers and trying to figure out
and he said he went up to his downs like
dad you know and you know my dad's one
of 13 shitload of kids it was dad we're
gonna do so should we start taking out
for the bunkers he does let me tell you
something son if Russia decides to send
a nuclear bomb here that bunker you can
do [ __ ] for you now so what you want to
do is stare at the view and appreciate
for one last time be an oven your
ghostie oven yeah so I grabbed a steak
is 13 over soref build a giant bunker
the food not to mention if it's our last
days on earth we'd only be staring in
the dark in this bunker you want one
last good view of that sky then we're
all gonna go when I was in the city was
like when I was our school when I was in
high school there was all the kids were
running around with no nukes stickers
the idea like it let's get ready to kill
the worms but all we thought about I'm
telling you oh as a kid when you were
when you were 14 15 16 as a kid in the
eighties you did probably at the
forefront of your brain every single day
was the fact that Russia and the United
States were at war and that at any given
time we could be annihilated off
planet is fast and you'd hear about the
ICBMs and you read about the amount of
firepower in just one missile and they
had a like a thousand missiles so it
could destroy the earth it would crack
the globe in half all these stories you
know and all we'd just be like is holy
[ __ ] and so kids would really we all
took it very hard we're like you know
and then it became this faith faith
fatalist kind of mentality you know my
dad's super into politics I don't really
touch on you guys know this we've
listened the show for the last 90 years
but I was talked to my dad and it's like
yeah you know this day and age you know
this it's so negative I was talking
about the negativity on social media and
just the news and stuff and then he goes
have you read and they start dropping
statistics and I went I felt like it's
better time in the sixties and seventies
went yeah why not use you what he was
rooting his base like you're a [ __ ] he
was no it's today's way better I mean
every in every aspect is better Studios
you got a ring throughout and you you
told me the same curse book that's was
you got to read that at cradles because
if you're just tuning to the CNN or
whatever you think the world's [ __ ]
ending he was but if you sit back and
yet she look at the numbers even
violence compared to the 69 he goes deaf
disease things better
yeah here's but what do you but you
choose to listen to this and I was like
and I learners pull up the Economist
Rosie alright dad well I'm an idiot I'll
call you later he had it call me
tomorrow he's he's right you know even
even the n-word the I think it's in in
Steven Pinker's book you can the the
United Nations says he's reared
statistics so the n-word they can tell
that equality like they do is equality
like what's the word ages you know to
see and they'll give it a number so how
do they measure quality one way it's a
look at how often the n-word is googled
for jokes and what age those people are
and what it turns out is the people that
are coming out with n-word jokes are
also researching Social Security so
they're way older but young people don't
do that in any country it's gone way
down a race there's only going inward
but they have all kinds of weird markers
that they can file it you know
but but also it's it's so [ __ ] true
here's a really quick quick thing just
to keep in mind from the 60 70s remember
that in the 70s and even a lot of the
80s all of South America all of Latin
America with the exception I think of
almost maybe close to Rica and all of
those all of them were under military
dictatorship they were all under mill
the military ran [ __ ] and and Pinochet's
Chile you know all these in Brazil
hensel's father yeah and so Gracie's
father was tortured by that buddy he
talks about it [ __ ] um they were you
were picked up off the street and
disappeared or you were tortured or all
kinds of things happen because you were
you were accused of being part of the
Communist Party you were accused of
being like North Korea these days it was
a military dictatorship not quite as bad
as North Korea and then you had then you
had remember you had literally half the
globe under Soviet domination that meant
that those people whether they were in
Poland whether they were in Hungary
Czechoslovakia you got to remember all
these places that you can go now that
are free they they they couldn't leave
their country you could not leave you
could not cross the border
you were given a house and you were the
other thing you were told what to think
and you didn't you couldn't vote how
about civil rights same thing exactly
civil rights about women I try 64 are
women's right 1964 when you guys have a
tough now go back to the 60s or if
you're a dude it was well what was what
was in 1964 then the Civil Rights Act
1964 three years before I was they say
that was because of JFK yeah I don't
believe in in many parts of the country
but how crazy is that black people could
not vote it was a state you can go to
the same bathroom yeah
drinks are the same fountain still in
the same car we've made the same schools
we've made sure I've seen [ __ ] we
have made strides yeah but my dad goes
that's because your heels remember
anyone only highlights the 67th the past
as it being the best to remember these
things yours no no no one more thing
keep in mind famines
in the 70s in India China just look that
up how many people's I do disease get
AIDS in the 70s let me know how that
forget it's smallpox polio diphtheria
mom skittles get the flu in the 30s game
over enjoy that kid allergies in the
1910s you're [ __ ] yep yep get a
toothache you get a bump on your dick
game over the old town signs less means
old town fight now gonna get to your
brain you can crazy jelly brain you can
get crazy and hoot what do what gangsta
happened to Al Capone Capone Al Capone
again listen digress [ __ ] like there's a
recurring theme of today's show died
crazy and in jail from [ __ ] kids yeah
so what's the message today penicillin
don't fly method no don't fight that's
why back in the day Deveney sucks why
are you back in the day you didn't [ __ ]
that's quite back in the day a woman
didn't lose her virginity everyone had
bushes yeah and they were always very
religious and when that bushes no one's
[ __ ] sure no one's getting their
dicks off before porn and seventies
there's not much dick sucked like porno
hair right you know that no yeah I was
frowned upon to get a young lady to suck
that dick was very tired oh no though
they say but who knows I'll tell you
what porn though since it's in all of
our brains sex has become a lot dirtier
because back in the day you didn't see
porn you'd get if you are lucky enough
somebody had some videotapes magazine
watch Thanks
I remember watching I was in high school
and my buddies dad had a porn on and
these girls were so hot and we were all
watching it and I was like I'm standing
there and I'm gone and I've been the
summer and I hadn't [ __ ] gotten laid
and you got ever wrong my [ __ ] was so
hard it was hard my dick was like I was
acting like this I was like that's crazy
look at his back up or what's he doing
up here honest what is just do you want
to run how long is this thing where'd
you get this anyway well it can I have
it yeah I was saying one thing I don't
stairs what would you jerk is I always
talk it
and lighten in my belt lines I had oh
you know how I'm built I had to stick it
right up my [ __ ] though cuz yeah I
had no other room I had to really I had
to lube it up it had to tie it around my
foot I had to stick it right up the old
[ __ ] it was disgusting but I had to
feel good though well it's the only
thing I can do in that situation so yeah
that is awkward when was the first time
you saw porn chin I don't know how all
that was but I watched said that duck
Howard the Duck movie during her no
that's a slow clap for Howard remember
most expensive movie during the time was
a total flop an absolute [ __ ] flop
one of my favorite movies and my
brothers is kid Howard the Duck dundun
dundun pleased you too Howard the dive
that turn you on
no there's a lot of [ __ ] there's a
stripper something what a porn porn ish
kind of scenes in it boss of the dude
Howard the Duck [ __ ] up dancer and
it's awesome these little tails like
boom boom boom Haley dude Howard Howard
[ __ ] I didn't know the woman [ __ ] a
duck yeah they're Thomson Duda Howard
the Duck sexy man go to that dude I know
we had Tom was this one yeah he [ __ ]
he's in a robe that's Marty McFly's mom
you [ __ ] oh I know my friend Howie
Deutsch his actual wife yeah well I'm
glad somebody's happy it's not I
remembered it dude how old is this movie
it is mataji me no look how good the
animation is not the animation but look
how cool Howard the Duck it's not a man
how was this movie a bomb is brilliant
you think I might find happiness in the
animal kingdom tacky like this you
cannot make this movie today I'm strange
kissing a baby oh no I'm not in the
beaks
look at Howard uh your mouth is so hard
to sharp okay oh you got those tiny
microscopic listen dude you cannot do
this today what do you mean okay
he's a speciality sort of dude you can't
be an AMC Theaters [ __ ] dumb [ __ ]
drug now the silver screen [ __ ]
aside go Camry softie let's be realistic
I mean Maya's got the blow don't stop
this chin chin was jacking off to this
at 8:00 well cos always thought of
himself as a duck she loves things and
then also watch ducks [ __ ] she also
likes to dress up like a duck in like
the floods house and she dresses like a
duck and Fox
it's just face look at this dude look
it's not I've a headache and I got the
aspirin should I get that password just
one goodnight kiss sweet duckie
maybe this isn't the scene
is the lead up bro just kidding
yeah and there's the enemy there this
yeah he's got your dick sucked bro like
a molest kids on theirs in the sex scene
but this is the lead up defies all the
laws of nature let me get this straight
Chan you jacked off to this I don't know
if I jacked off at this point when I was
this young Jin I'm gonna ask you a
question I should be dead sir - Brian
damn it we know for quite some time here
you're safe here trust no one is you
know what you're in the duck pond bro
you're talking through ducks here bring
your voice down
bring that get him go get him go just do
worse - ducks here I'm not too worried
let me ask you something yeah I'll suck
your [ __ ] seen well I don't know what's
going on there when you scroll to
youporn pornhub whatever you use
what do you search for I have some ideas
what you do what do you think I do what
do you think right I guess chin jacked
if I had to guess today what is he put
in the bar yeah yeah I'd say he probably
puts I think he probably puts bb-dub
young young young no I say he probably
says middle-aged white guys tied up in a
business that's what that's what I yeah
I want to be slaughtered and it was a
question it notes no result no so you
keep searching and he puts in when he's
really gone when he's really kind of
where he goes he just writes him [ __ ]
slaughtered and eaten that would be my
guess [ __ ] slaughtered and eaten eat
I think he's looking at Asian some sort
of Asian a particular agent I don't know
how I don't know how I don't get
teleported I really don't I didn't tell
you guys I don't know I don't either cuz
I don't believe it I definitely believe
it I Lee I believe I live in the old
memory bank this thing here CT my ass
I kept the rolodex
I was with our brains like this a real
quick answer Jim what do you usually
look at I used to look at Asian I was
young not anymore do you look at let me
ask you white man Asian girl no Asian on
Asian it's not a lot of that it is like
they're bushes
it's interracial that's for sure oh you
go black you go black that's best times
that's a problem there's a you go black
on Asian you know white white white
women okay and then black dudes okay you
know that's pretty common fine
interesting chin I would've got that
funny mix it up there studs there's
something about that that situation
that's hard situation yeah that's a
popular search I'm with I would have
guessed that a thousand tries I'm with
Stevie he's with his girl this girl he
knows not his girl but a girl a girl yep
that friend and we start talking about
things and we porn comes out by camera
more how and I said you watch but she
was talking away and I said you watched
porn she goes yeah of course I said what
are you watching she goes gangbangs just
like that gangbangs like and she nodded
like well obviously well I was like well
that's not obvious well we got a we got
a part of your on her hand yeah we got a
part that's a read that's together
awesomeness interesting yeah question
you hmm interesting chin I don't just
regular white on white very rare i watch
the certain actresses yeah certain ones
I don't what are you looking for a girl
who's a real freak who really gets off
no no no no no no like a lot of dicks in
the video but I don't like old gang man
like too much you like you like a
lovemaking video do you know those don't
know no not I hate those who it says
sensual scene like what the cloud nine
you want who's Jack into that I want
some heart-pounding American sex yeah by
search by the by the the talent you know
you know I'm saying okay there grab some
faves oh you got certain phase one is
Asian Creek yeah awesome awesome yeah
she's one of my face so should get sure
razy what she'll do show up you will
open that he commits Cooper right up
fast she doesn't have fast she full
asses
sometimes should double ass yeah even
triple I've seen with her that room yeah
my will turn I will turn off and write
her a note you turn that off now
so there's that who else do you God I
don't have some I don't know bangbros
always delivers bangbros
Bank Rose the hottest girls a quality
company what go trick me because
sometimes I'm like bro that's a normal
girl they found on the street and she's
a dime piece don't commit you though
yeah and then show I don't mind the
English taxi one either with his cameras
all over the taxi I haven't seen that
one I'm gonna see me much tax when he
picks up the hot girl he's like where he
had it and he's going what are you doing
he goes we know I don't know if you're
into it but I won't charge if you suck
this dick she's like okay and then they
go in the back and it's a nice setup
back there
Wow very English dude skinny dude decent
side dick but you believe it you know
yeah now do you do you ever see how I'll
go with the guys I like my like a little
rocco siffredi of course you do that
yeah nope never never searched for the
dudes myself but I can see why you would
being a gay man yeah well I just like
that they they commit you know I don't
like sometimes when goes suggestions for
you only I don't know why you put trans
on there once in a while how in the
world do you get a chick with a dick
into my searches that is so interesting
cuz once in a while you'll be stronger
through pornhub or whatever it might be
and all of a sudden it's just a
gentleman going a town on another man
and it's just man on man look I'm like
how'd this thumbnail suiza very bright I
know it might be because I'm putting a
mic put might be a case [ __ ] dude oh
okay [ __ ] young Foucault cipher already
look like the name is sucks [ __ ] no but
that might be the problem it might be
gone gay and I put I'm gay calm that's
go that's what did it Oh on your face
yeah that's your tab I got I got to
learn how to I can't I don't know the
search engines I don't I work this thing
how's your networks
ah how this works busting busting you
know well I told you when my my my
daughter was very young I was in
Pittsburgh and she was six months old I
don't know if you ever heard my wife
tell this story and my daughter is six
months old and we hired a babysitter
because my wife and I were gonna go out
and have a very nice a meal and I had I
had used my wife's computer too because
I got home late to to rub one out like
the dirt bag I was while my child and my
wife was slept in the other room because
I'm a I need help with another room
you're yeah yeah and and but I just
lazily shut it because you know all the
popups that used to come off yeah they
still pop up okay so I again I wore
myself out with the porn stuff but I did
that and when my wife opened to MapQuest
where we were gonna be for the
babysitter but all that stuff came up
honest it was a big problem and I said
I'm very sorry I thought you can do said
I know it'll shut up okay all right I
said that was and I blamed my friend I
said I said Johnny got ahold the
computer that scumbag and he was showing
me a girl and you know you should done
I'm sorry for this you guys absolutely
right I was jacking off last night yeah
now have a good day yeah well and go the
Suzy young lady and I I was intensely
embarrassed that I do it yeah that stuff
is embarrassed you bring cotton with
anything like that your parents are
taught you jacking off or killing people
no I'm lucky I know people have been
caught never tugging your buds so I'm
very very careful yeah yeah I bet you're
you cover all your bases yep here's a
tower or a seller or a dungeon my
ability is little sketch in ah
Deven we take a quick break yeah all
right cool do we need to add it all that
outer all right get some current events
yeah let's get some current events God
do how about we start off with this
first one which is kind of surprising
UFC 227 their estimated pay-per-view
numbers are in and it's around 300,000
pay-per-view which is amazing it's good
huh yeah for the for the temperature of
pay-per-views in their model you know
include myself I thought this things you
do around a hundred some right and you
know it's trending
you know on Instagram and with all that
stuff in em so I turned on Twitter so
those usually result in pay-per-view
buys and you know the shape does around
300,000 buys which makes me excited
because that means TJ and Cody and Cody
get paid but you can really get double
your pay if to hit around that 400 mark
really so hopefully it comes in more
like 400 okay that's good they need to
calculate in like the the the buying or
the somehow the streaming the illegal
streaming I don't know how they would do
that and obviously I'm sure they're on
it they're smart people but god that's
killing these guys who are banking on
those 400,000 pay-per-view buys good
good for in this gives uh this gives TJ
negotiation powder now power now you
know going into things like alright well
you put me on that huge card before so
we don't really know where I was that
now we know on a [ __ ] card the worst
card of the year I still sold 300,000
right so it's great for color for DJing
Cody right yeah largest live crowd there
to every people center remember remember
at that Stadium Ronda Rousey fought Liz
Carmouche also above well was no I'm
sorry that was in Anaheim
so Zingano Zynga a rousing Zingano the
the Ronda fought Liz Carmouche at in
Anaheim also on that card which is a
huge draw was Brendan Schaub virtual
hard John I mean that was one of the
most anticipated fights of the day I
don't want to say it was a pure snooze
fest but I took him down over and over
at the time was a lot of take today the
me dog yeah and he also got busted for
peds awesome prison out for aiding women
so there's that
yeah he's a rough fella you get a nice
guy to me wanna knock my [ __ ] head
square off very good hit hard puncher
so we call him a power puncher yeah what
else another cool thing about this is
the UFC 227 was the most searched google
term that day Wow
that the most thing ever judged that day
good for UFC has been having travel
ratings wise but the but now listen
what's good if
a UFC Fan MMA fan in general Bellator is
flying under the radar cuz UFC is
announcing just some [ __ ] heaters
with Connor khabib Nate Diaz pori ADC
Lesnar you got all this cool stuff
happening right GSP there's looming so
there's all this cool stuff going you'll
see meanwhile Bellator dropped their
welterweight tournament which is
ridiculous ridiculous you have Rory
MacDonald fighting Mustapha their
meaning they drop announced rights do
anything so ya know you know could say
dropped I mean they release some yeah I
can tell Brian yeah hold on yeah so drop
me so belt or drop their announcement of
the war at all yeah Roy McDonald who's
fighting in it which is crazy but then
he got he's fighting Mousasi before that
so he's gonna he's a hundred dog against
musasa which is i see ii am Stephanie
how's he doing 85 oh boy he's going up
there to get his belt so Rory at he's
fighting in this tournament and look you
look at the bracket you got John Fitch
you got Rory you got Edie Ruth who's a
[ __ ] monster
you got [ __ ] on the other bracket got
Paul de Leeuw verse Michael venom page
in the first round you got Lima burrs
that Cora for shades really Michael
venom page fought in the past no they
hate each other doing long time coming
yeah Paul that'd be the most watch fight
all day Lisa Louise
so old Paul Daley was fighting you've
been doing forever before Nick Diaz was
even in the UFC
well Strikeforce that's that's we got
there he's been doing it either way
Bellator is announced some heaters and
no one's and then remember you still
have phaidor verse channel coming up Wow
you selves Ryan beta verse material
coming up I'm telling you man Bellator
is kicking ass do you think gotta keep
up with it yeah but it's a good time to
be a MMA fan between Bellator and what
your C is doing like things are all good
man you can hate on the ratings all you
want even I'm critical of their ratings
but in general things are [ __ ] good
man count White's never been bigger
matchup wise has never been better
you got Connor coming back the king is
back you get to be the Russian nightmare
you got the super fights you
she's just Johnson just lost so you have
this kind of transition period right now
at flyweight which they've always needed
he's gonna be out you have any pseudo
who wants to fight TJ TJ let's fight him
super fight they're not gonna happen you
think I think so cuz DJ DJ would get on
automatic rematch usually for being that
great of a champion yes but he's out
here's a broken foot yes so right yeah
and there's no one there so Henry
suniverse TJ makes sense although Henry
doesn't it's really a 35-pound anyway
they they could fight at 25 or 35
doesn't matter both armor down for
either what else get gen just on that
topic so TJ and Henry scimitar were on
extra TV in front of Mario Lopez and
they both brought their belts like
they're kind of sort of promoting it
already have you seen this clipper so
let me just just let me just go on posit
for a second so listen the way this
works is the UFC booked this on purpose
so if you guys think this is a
coincidence that hange Sahu do and TJ
Dillashaw
are on extra with Mario Lopez I wasn't
that that didn't just happen
Henry Henry saludos agent and T general
I cave what you're on here - whoa no the
UFC was like hey let's put each other
they weren't just walking down the
street at Mario's in the middle and
cameras happen to be there is everything
AC Slater just doesn't pop up and
interview huh what do they say here I'll
play for you wait come here come here
come here
TJ I'm at that's it cover with your ass
for brother then I lose leg out or
something cool moment right here cuz we
got to UFC champions right here very
very dedicated and they're talking to
each other right here now obviously
y'all respect each other but you feel
very confident always Mike were too
happy absolutely I'll run through them
taking that Bell drivers shoulder all
right I'm Henry you have know how big is
Henry sudafed it's the golden rule and
dad with the gold make sure I got more
gold in me brother what do you guys all
got gold right here so no I got
[ __ ] how would I approach I'd knock them
out all right that's it and I see the
last thing you try to fly what you got
there verify we do you imagine please
you got not that please you see let's
let me imagine find a fly I hope either
you come down or go on I'm coming down
around your shoulder that's a life you
got you got to you got to serious
competitors on good luck to these
gentlemen please check out UFC flyweight
champion Henry said we're going his next
fight and UFC bantamweight champion TJ
do you know any more competitive than
teach the same thing to fierce
competitors
oh yeah yeah yeah they're pretty fierce
but see TJ before a fight like a
backstage I mean nothing to them I
didn't work hardest [ __ ] say Nana but
I think TJ would beat him
I think TJ ISM yeah I I actually and I
watched that pseudo deejay fight twice
such a close fight and everywhere I
didn't think he was taking taken nothing
from him oh really
I'll see more than one round for DJ
really Oh see I thought DJ was more busy
the whole time low kick more busy
doesn't any win fights yeah he got taken
down a bunch but why why do you say that
cuz he got taken out taken down I
thought when he was on that see that see
that that's where you get [ __ ] that's
why when this is most people some people
on your side when they go well he didn't
control down he didn't do it that does
not matter the rule book does not say
you have to do this in this in order for
it to be a takedowns are scored okay
that's a dominate that's a dominating
maneuver when your ass hits the ground
it's a takedown yeah that is a takedown
does the most significant thing and the
last result he won he won that fight so
I don't think anybody felt like that was
a robbery and all they do and he does I
think that pseudo on some people had it
for one for DJ which I find [ __ ] fat
DJ was so so active so you saw him
kicking a lot you saw him throwing
punches he was a [ __ ] active - man
those takedowns are significant
significant I made energizer yeah
amazing and any control demand so when
you look at the fight like well that was
the most dominating thing that
and over a few rounds Henry yeah I
didn't find it close but here's the
problem
everyone has their biases when you judge
a fight yeah maybe you're a wrestling
fan you know in DC out of great comedy
goes those are takedowns and wrestling
in the sport of wrestling that counts as
a takedown so everyone's you know we
popped up or I did this that is a
clear-cut dominating position those you
think Henry does the same thing to teach
you as far as taking them down um
there's a different animal it's a great
fight great fight well yeah and TJ's a
bigger fighter longer so it'll be their
chief TJ's a better wrestle in it than
Mighty Mouse TJ in a wrestling call yeah
yeah yeah it's gonna be really
interesting do you use a bigger guy I
will never bet against TJ nor should you
what else you got Jen [ __ ] moms
another one from MMA do you remember
Anjali that girl that had a husband who
had a tattoo all the Nazis get removed
know how to remove double down got one
on his neck wait here I'm here Nazi
tattoo yeah from his from way back in
the days he was part of that what I
would call it not Nazis but neo-nazi
kind of so here's the story to fill you
in bean but yeah this is uh from four
months ago yeah you know I've gone Brian
right now so um yeah how you doin
eighteen so Lee took a picture and she
was on vacation like a lake house and
her husband's there and he has a Nazi
tattoo on his for frost iike swastika
and so gotta get rid of that well and so
she posts that and he's her coach so he
walks her to the hawk gun so there's all
see huge backlash rooms like what the
[ __ ] you have you have Nazi tattoos and
you have sponsors right and you have and
you have sponsors it's like what are you
doing and then he had to come out and
defend himself and she defend him off
see that's her husband he was I usually
cover him up I didn't want bringing a
ger attention these tattoos were from a
long time ago you know and and I'm not a
Nazi
you haven't laser he was out in prison
and he goes you know I was in prison so
I made the choice then yeah but also but
also with the Nazis such that it's a
swastika so of on your floor of course
of
course laser that [ __ ] off of course
find the time in your day like here's
the thing but do anything I got I got so
I got the pickup dog food I got you know
I gotta go pick up the kids or whatever
I go to the Chams sure I gotta go get
some food and then maybe I gotta get I
go to the dentist I gotta take a [ __ ]
you have a you have a swastika on your
forearm it would be better if you cover
it with a penguin named a male animal
and cover those busy to get rid of the
swastika tax then he goes ite said it so
it reminds me of my history and the
mistakes I make other people here's a if
you put a penguin on there it's gonna
remind you of that [ __ ] memory of the
Squatch get that do it also a swastika
is that - I know this is a surprise but
also remind some people have bulldozing
Jews in by the thousands by million yeah
so a bad picture Birds right there that
might be any worse Patriot notice see
yeah yeah again just it's small
just [ __ ] cover it up so what's the
story though chin story is that guy
allegedly beat her up recently right
always a kind this is also a convicted
killer that's why he was in jail in the
first place he shot someone seven times
well as many many years ago arm out so
he's got a swastika nice shot a do seven
times when they beat his wife up so you
know it might be the chance you know
here's here's an anger issue oh oh no oh
hold on get out what terrible person one
of he sucks here's what I'm most
surprised about that he was able to beat
her up she's [ __ ] talented yeah but
that is her husband I'm sure her coach
she probably knows a weak spot a coach
maybe it's her Tamia nothing to laugh
about obviously so she has a roommate
that live with him - and then she this
particular person made a statement to
the police about what this guy yeah he
tried to burn some burn a cigarette on
her arm her body she's yelling stop
trying to burn her open up the door and
was like Donnie
don't name yourself Donnie Donnie leave
her alone he looked like he was lost he
ain't slept in two days don't care he
was drinking for two [ __ ] days
straight alcoholic I don't know what
he's on I'm backing up as he is coming
towards me andrea was button up her
shorts and she was barefoot and ran out
the back door he's [ __ ] up because
Donnie used to be a cop okay he's [ __ ]
up in the head he's making her do things
they're trying to fake evidence that she
was cheating he was trying to get her to
pull off her pants and take pictures
send her a guy so it looked like she
sent it he's [ __ ] in the head they've
been arguing all week she couldn't train
because he kept her home that's good he
couldn't he wouldn't let her leave I
didn't call the cops until it got
physical and couldn't do anything more
Adam Escobar has been going on for years
I just never saw it as a convicted
killer in a shooting death he's a former
police he checks all with a Nazi okay
the convicted in 2009 of negligent
homicide with a firearm after shooting
an armed man seven times he escaped more
serious charges of manslaughter that
could have planted them prison for 40
years and then now so there is a found a
real gem there's a arrest warrant out
for him now good good I'll be [ __ ]
rot in jail Jesus Christ man she had fun
new camp huh or die
hopefully it's over now hopefully she
leaves yeah all right this one here
about Maryland's football team football
grounds Bo and the guy that died Jordan
McNair who was apparently they were
hardcore bad to him when he was passing
out so here's the things I wrote have
you read to my Russian evangelist on
debts man so here's basically what's
going on
Maryland football right - big time -
vigilant football the tariffs so they
are going through conditioning and
there's conditioning tests you have to
run I think ten 100-yard Sprint's it's
pretty standard like we did at
University of Colorado like there's
condition tests and what they're trying
to do when you do these condition tests
are weed out the weak links so it's
pretty all I wants a military issue
and not as hard as the military but
they're trying to get rid of the guys
who aren't gonna cut it
yeah so you go through these condition
tests and if you're failing that get the
[ __ ] off the team
- only dead weight so when that happens
not everyone's gonna pass it so they you
know they some of these kids on in the
interview said it was bullying god I'm
gonna kid dies you don't want that but
so the kid wasn't doing well and he was
having heatstroke and so they kept
pushing him so he told the coach told
two players go pick him up drag his ass
across to finish this we can't have any
quitters well the kid went through
heatstroke and they said he was like he
said Bolivar the kid died yeah of
heatstroke correct me if I'm wrong
though that like never seen a program
not do this by the way pretty stands of
times it's happened you get a death
which is always tragic but you can't you
can't take a culture mmm that makes me
boys out of men men out of boys and and
because one person dies and said that
that's bad because that would have been
a story that he would have told with
pride later on and a lot of people have
like they pick me up drag me but I made
it through you know those are the
stories that look like the military go
through boot camp my god man like that
that [ __ ] sergeant I wouldn't office
I hate Navy SEALs be if you didn't if
you didn't tweet out for release them
now I know it's horrible they didn't
they did not take the proper procedures
and he should not have died but as far
as him going you know this kid going
they want me gain weight so they made me
sit at the training table [ __ ] eat
almost threw up well God gabbro guys
don't throw up you like I try to be a
tough guy here I'm saying in general
that's what you signed obviously
programs are that way could wrestling
programs do you go to d1 go go to Iowa's
wrestling programs big-time football go
to Ohio State it's a little Florida
State you can die in training all the
time in the military yeah we have a very
strong military nobody's gonna tell you
yeah and it's and also remember it's so
competitive and there's so much money
being made there trying to get rid of
the weak links so it can't be an rah-rah
atmosphere that does not make good
football teams it just does it
somebody always does die of heatstroke
very rarely yeah who is stringer from
the is not that calm and out of all the
guys who played football of all the high
level programs this isn't that common so
you know for this I had a hard case make
here's what you can't do and I think
your grids be we can't do is go oh my
god football culture is [ __ ] terrible
we got to change everything now so what
they do they fired the strength
condition coach said he's creating a
bully atmosphere he I don't feel like
that's the right way what you should do
is fire the the [ __ ] trainers who
didn't make the right calls and work
fast enough and then put cold water on
them and didn't get them to the
emergency room fast enough that's
probably their job not the strength
condition coach's job also also
sometimes [ __ ] happens and I agree
arable sometimes you're everybody's
doing their job and somebody dies and
and and and you know I'm saying like
that's gonna happen regardless now I
will say this if that was my son that's
my family yeah I want that [ __ ]
fire core want that College brush down
so I get why they're so upset that's why
you don't help me from my football
background when i when i read this
oregon it oh my god I've been through
worse than that but you know this is
that that that was high school for me
that's high school that's the difference
being subjective law and objective law
subjective law would be you because you
had an egregious thing done to you
you're gonna want to shut the whole
thing down you can't make laws like that
you have to be objective unfortunately
you have to be you have to look at the
bigger picture and say this program has
been in place forever this was one that
have been accessible also subjective is
where we get those lone shooters yeah
right it everything's there the victim
Irit the world's horrible politics are
horrible but if you look at the grand
scale it's all good baby joined this
look listen to them over here but they
stick the subjective views it sucks at
the students I can't imagine but what
I'm saying is in football culture and
hard knocks doesn't mean they just hit
the very iceberg of the way coaches talk
and what they talking in the rooms in
the film rooms they don't show that but
the you know this is very standard and
any program you go to inner strength
against your coaches their jobs are on
the line so their job is to make sure
that teams in shape strong
injury-free and they're under pressure
so when the kids not finishing the
condition tests of course they're going
what the [ __ ] get up and finish yeah
what is the can you jump over to Urban
Meyer for sect if he weathered that
storm I haven't heard but that's my god
that's a little all time that's a
solution job over a position coach who
with domestic violence right I mean an
urban goes what you don't even told him
you know you get fired right if this
comes out true you get fired yeah they
said urban didn't do enough so he should
she has to do you know how busy that
guy's job is and we want you want to be
marriage counselor
should he go to the house he did have
meals with them and he did try to like
work it out with that I supposed to do
I'm about Brenner been around a lot of
coaches I've been super fortunate some
of the best in the world there's not a
better hands-on player two player
players coach who also has told the
lines planners they ride and die for
it's insane not to mention his track
record at Utah Florida you know the
shehnai is that Florida that went on and
he was able to met
he's the Phil Jackson of college
football when you're Mabel to manage all
those crazy dudes and make him work free
to get the next champ ship and then Ohio
State I mean the pressure at Ohio
State's insane man yeah and he's
performing and then this [ __ ] [ __ ]
who hits his wife you know Urban Meyer's
trying to put out all these fires he
can't solely focus on that we're trying
to win national championships you gotta
be honest Knorr is his job that's not
his job that should be the athletic
director that should be someone else it
should be a marriage and they're saying
are theirs it's not anybody's job like
the problem is they're saying Urban knew
about it and didn't do it what are you
supposed to do so wait okay let's go to
know that I know so you're having
problems with your wife you both love
each other and you're having major
problems you might even get physical
first of all first thing everybody does
goes it's none of my business you get
involved in a domestic dispute good see
how they with somebody who rest talks
about it yeah yeah everybody knows that
that's a complicated thing like what the
[ __ ] do you want me to do I'm busy as
[ __ ] you want me to get involved in your
I don't know how to help and and I'm not
there and I don't see what's going on
it's all here stirred I see that stuff
and it breaks my heart man like dude you
guys are trying to go after the wrong
King guys the paralyzer the good guy
public square is unforgiving the public
square doesn't give a [ __ ] about details
public squares is likes to see the
destruction of somebody and it doesn't
matter how what your track record is
what you did in the past you suck what
else you got Jin Gooden current event
sir all right thanks
how about how about hard not true quick
oh [ __ ] yes [ __ ] yes how about on Hard
Knocks that like they've lost our
receivers first round draft pick and
they kick it off by showing him in his
crib he's like 250 shoes they're staying
out it's gonna be a big year for him
then they show him practice like kind of
half-ass in it and he was a first team
with his first-round draft pick it's
kind of half-assed in the coach like
come on do like Ron like get to the
[ __ ] ball remember it's the [ __ ]
and a foul I get in dirt they're telling
a first-round draft pick who makes a
million Dodge
dude you gotta run to the ball you got
to do this and so they pull on the
second team he comes it's the way that
so kicks off come to the head coach's
office huge huge acts I think walks and
goes what the [ __ ] man I'm on the second
team what are we doing if you're not
gonna play me just trade me next day bo
sent a buffalo we're a seventh round
pick or six round pick they pick you
excuse me very cool we don't need that
here have a good day see ya oh let's
play out other guys and now hopefully
they bring in Dez Bryant please was my
team know what else you get you all
right this article is about Jerry
Seinfeld talking about James guns firing
and him using jokes
so in Seinfeld's opinion he said if
they're jokes they're just jokes they're
not real so if it's really bad then that
that's a comedian not doing the the job
well and it's not a joke anymore
if that makes any yeah you know I'm I
talked to the mic Serna [ __ ] who
actually like ended up doing sending
those tweets like making those tweets
public and Mike servers it was that was
a First Amendment where I was no no no
he my sandwich I said to him I said what
you know was you know I had met him in
this thing and he said essentially well
the guy's a the guys you know kind of a
hypocrite and I said what I mean he goes
well he's a real so he's always been a
social justice warrior like he came
after to Roseanne so hard for that sweet
tweet like [ __ ] her and almost
yeah the director so subway when that
feels like boy this guy's this guy's
really coming after people apparently he
does James Gunn who by all accounts is a
good guy from what I'm from amazing
director but but but he does he is also
active on Twitter
trying to get people very very very
vocal from what I understand I don't
know I haven't done my research but I
talked to certain because he has been
very active always it feels that guy
says that he's very [ __ ] but he's
also been he's been very very came after
Rosanna ruthlessly he came after
everybody so so service was like well
let's see what this guy's tweeted I get
it fine so he didn't get him fired he
just made those tweets if we can follow
here you go I'll [ __ ] that guy I'm out
man [ __ ] that dude I'm sorry zero I can
kick in the nuts right but I mean it
this is how are you that this but again
lost is funnier but I like it like I say
if you're in the game if you're in the
game and you're assassinating other
people what's good for the goose is good
for the game so Jerry Seinfeld says who
I [ __ ] loved I didn't read the jokes
but if they're jokes it doesn't matter
I guess Roseanne Barr thought she was
being funny but it wasn't funny and if
it's offensive and not funny then it's
not a joke see Roseanne's wasn't really
a joke was him but she's a comedian
yeah but any comedian that doesn't
understand that dynamic you're finished
anyway Barr was also fired from Disney
weeks before a gun Steinfeld gave us
thoughts it seems like you don't need to
murder someone that's committing suicide
I thought the firing was overkill she's
already dead Wow
jokes are not real people assume that
when you say something that you believe
it it's purely comedic invention you
know I do this whole bit about Pop Tarts
and how much I love them I don't love
pop-tarts just funny it's funny say so I
said hmm I don't know James Gunn I don't
know if enough about this but you know
what I do know is there's a ton of
people sticking up for him yeah like you
like people who I was not a he's because
he's not a child molester he was those
were creepy they were creepy they were
creepy Dylan again the guy who'd the guy
oh man in public just all he did is he
goes hold on you're very very active on
Twitter you you come after people you're
30 ruthless that's dico that's a lot so
that's kind of what he does he's a
lawyer he's a firstly blind no he's a
First Amendment law so what he does
yes so he's like let's not be hypocrites
here hold on there's something called
freedom of speech if you're gonna do
that if the left is gonna do that you
know let's let's take a look at you know
the day the yeah that was the argument
so I don't know can't be my friend I
feel like yeah no suggestion did you
guys see that girl that pushed her
friend off a bridge yes sure the [ __ ]
didn't did she die no but check it out
there a messenger she was trying to mess
around but it was terrible when you
watch it she was supposed to Champa and
she got scared yeah you I'm sure you
asked for all there there's a river like
a lake yeah so now I up is it that's
sexy I heard 60 feet I heard that that's
very I jump through her jump through
jump 30 feet I've done 45 and too high
I swear to God it's the scariest thing
I've heard all my life I will know when
I say this you're never doing again 45
we call it so hot a few beers all my
other friends went and I went oh my god
I'm not doing this thing well there's no
way to get down you have to jump and
there's some kind of boat went do it you
[ __ ] not that one I have to do it yeah
and I jumped and it was hands down the
scariest thing I've ever done
walked a knock gun nah swelled up crowd
at the Wilbert nah jumping off a [ __ ]
rock was by far the worst thing I've
ever done in my life
I will never do that again yeah let me
see this [ __ ] jump you look like it
feels like you're jumping a million
miles down when you're up there right
that's why it's so smart
it's from the boat oh it that's not that
yeah god you're looking down oh my god
I'm coming off the Empire State Building
yeah yeah that's what it feels like
60 feet before tea five feet I've jumped
30 feet and it was terrifying dude I was
45 feet 60 feet this is 60 feet it's
like I if I slip it's literally game
over take it why am I doing this pros
cons
and this dum-dum all right so I'll let
you see it please but she doesn't want
to jump ready
look at that push to hear that she belly
flop belly flopped dude is she okay
No so she survived her face [ __ ] up
eyes so there goes more than three
stories before belly flop when the river
below
father resolved in six broken ribs two
punctured lungs and multiple internal
injuries and cuts the girl has also has
a mass behind her when windpipe
McDonald left is the one
pushed and the girl the right it was the
one day oh god there's the hot one yeah
the ugly one push let's not yelling
that's not my social media man you can
destroy somebody's life because she was
probably dumb maybe drunk whatever she's
like ah do it and she's choking around
and and you know didn't mean to
the girl who pushed her I'm sure it
didn't mean to tell that her friends the
apology scroll down she received a
single apology via text
well she probably doesn't know what to
say I mean she probably you know she's
young yeah she's young she's young it's
I can't defend it cuz I'd be honest I
was young and stupid I would have never
done that I know but some people are
stupid yeah that's true they're stupid
there are people that are stoop you'll
pros/cons pushing my friend off a bridge
we've all had friends at Han do him
falling breaking their neck last raid
livers broken eyes we're not gonna be
friends
breaks the another [ __ ] over Pro a
few friends laugh they jump in the river
everyone like that we all have that one
friend in the group who's stupid and
he's around and he's usually a good
person harmless but he's doop and you
get older he's the guy working at
t.j.maxx in a full sweat suit losing his
hair very out of shape hitting you up
for money he's probably a troll on
Instagram right your biggest troll
probably that's how that goes
yeah what else you got I love t.j.maxx
by the way no hey that's Jake no hate
t.j.maxx Aerosmith announced that
they're gonna do they're having a
residency in Las Vegas I think for three
months alright has Aerosmith fence I was
in the mm-hmm I would watch Steven Tyler
do his thing sure they're great bad
alright put up sketch in give me there's
two more two more so let me see if I can
find it so remember that guy Steve Perry
I know journey Perry he didn't sing
since 1998 yeah he is now returned he is
that him singing right there something
in the works
something was something's off about this
yeah it's a bit of a hater though you
guys judge for yourselves that's what
I'm doing one of the greatest voices in
rock'n'roll was definitely
[Music]
okay I'm not mad at the B I'm not mad at
it so far does he hit the high note
[Music]
he's still crushes
I'm not mad at no [ __ ] favorite click
on that still bottom right live in
Houston oh god I was on that that's when
he was going on that before you [ __ ] on
this man this is when he was the man no
how old is he in that video I know I
know he's married 57 hey dude so you
imagine [ __ ] Houston right now just a
small-town boy well nobody can nobody
can mimic his voice well I can a little
bit okay seventy million views
[Music]
look at its outfit son you guys make
funny for the cheetah print [ __ ] [ __ ]
you that [ __ ] is dull Steve Perry is the
[ __ ] boss well dude you can't say
boss Bruce what do you think he's he's
the bomb
sure okay do the lyrics not that I
didn't like it the title racing yeah a
racer you're racing terrible I'm gonna
watch it I'm gonna watch that video on a
list that song I love Steve Perry there
I said it
what else kitchen once it okay let me
just do a quick one here I don't know
what this is but just watch this those
alligators how crazy is that
there's a shrimp this shrimp I don't
know if this is real no I'd never find
anything on this is really why they do
they protect themselves from a threat
Wow yeah yeah let super impose the music
on there of course they keep like just
together in sync all three of them never
see it one more time give me one moment
I don't want to end on crawfish dancer I
think they don't like this maldita head
you've heard that ya know suck the tails
eat dead yeah suck the heads all right
this is a during a postgame show for the
Braves did you see the security guard no
it was almost unnecessary that he ran
through here but check it out take city
so someone behind these guys opens up a
little baby shirt that says Harper on it
and it security runs after just each no
he didn't need to run there let me see
it one more time okay Freddie Freeman
just shown a shirt and then he leaves
scorpion two is ladies gave oh you did
did the water warm to have it Jim that's
pretty much it
let's go the scorpion blown up and a
scorpion brother
I'm trying think what news we owe our
Phoenix show that Super Show a sold out
I love it there's I think there's only
no it's sold out it's sold out so with
Theo von Bryan Callen big J Ari Shaffir
myself the in October end of October
that shows sold out so you know we're
doing you know we're doing that it's
it's gonna be announced next week we're
doing another show same night to show
about that three thousand tickets I like
it that's six thousand total son I like
what's up dog I like it we releasing it
yeah
get tickets to be announced next week
sounds good and then September 13th I'm
in Vancouver there are less than 100
tickets left
Vancouver Commodore theater then
September 13th and then the week after
that I'm in Chicago Schaumburg improv
Chicago and the week after that I'm in
Seattle that's all in September I will
see you on the road doggies and also
there are 100 shirts left with limited
edition chin bursts Bryan Callen vintage
boxing teeth t5k calm roots a fight
collab get them there's only 100 left
get them right now
keep Afghan calm to charities to
announce one August 26 for pancreatic
cancer my buddy I lost my buddy and his
wife is doing this thing every year it's
at the Comedy Store August 26 which is a
Sunday then I'm gonna be performing on
that show I'm probably gonna get some
comics to do that but August 30th is
also another charity I'm doing and I'll
be there you'll be there it'll be
Brendan Schaub Joe Rogan Chris D'Elia
Theo von Brian count now is that line
I'm not a bad line and I bet I might
have somebody else who knows boom but
what do we need anybody else but I don't
think so so you guys come on get your
tickets at the Comedy Store comm gear
I'm y'all thank you for listening
we will see you on the road around town
the model of this episode is guys like
the [ __ ] guys like to [ __ ] guys who like
to [ __ ] we cover it all but guys you
[ __ ] boom this the fire tune we're out